et vous vous installez dans le 16e
arrondissement quand même il n'y avait
des gens qui me prenaient pour le
concierge parce que j'étais heureuse
du samedi 20h ce soir Linda de Suza
monstre
alors
ancienne femme de chambre devenu star
dans les années 80 vous avez vendu plus
de 20 millions de disques votre
autobiographie la valise en carton a été
un best-seller absolu avec 3 millions
d'exemplaires écoulés aujourd'hui Linda
vous vivez avec une retraite de femmes
de ménage de 400 euros et vous racontez
votre histoire dans un livre intitulé
des larmes d'argent publié aux éditions
carnet Nord et à 20h dans sa lutter rien
[Musique]
Linda de Suza rebonsoir alors Théo Linda
jokaïna des sous-sol ça c'est votre vrai
nom hein
de sauce
c'est toujours mieux vous êtes né le 22
février 1948 à beringles
alors
moi aussi
vos parents qui auront 11 enfants
travaillaient dur dans les champs et
votre problème en fait c'est que votre
mère ne vous aime pas c'est que quand
vous approchez d'elle vous avez droit à
un regard comme ça qui dit en gros
laisse-moi tranquille vous l'appelez
Victoria vous la vouvoyer il y a
vraiment pas de relation fimères et
pourquoi elle vous aimez pas
le découvertes à l'âge de 60 ans parce
qu'avant qu'elle nous quitte Victoria
m'a donné un petit bout de papier avec
une photo et maintenant je cherche ma
vraie mère
sa personne ne savait c'est pour ça moi
non plus maintenant
alors au début des années 50 votre
famille va s'installer à Lisbonne votre
mère trouve une place de bonne chez une
dame qui accepte d'héberger tout le
monde mais dans une petite chambre ce
qui fait que pendant que votre mère
travaille chez cette dame vous attendez
dans un jardin public qu'elle ait fini
de travailler exactement alors quand
votre mère tombe malade la tuberculose
vous avez cinq ans vous retrouvez dans
un orphelinat vous allez y rester six
ans et quand elle vient vous récupérer
quand même après toutes ces années elle
a pas changé en fait elle vient vous
chercher parce qu'elle a juste besoin
d'aide à la maison ah au fait le ménage
la cuisine la lessive et alors tous les
jours vous allez à pied chercher à
manger pour toute la famille 5 km et
demi dans un sens 5 km et demi dans
l'autre exactement
nous empêche pas votre mère de d'être
très très dur avec vous elle vous traite
de [ __ ] toute la journée et elle
encourage votre père à vous taper dessus
et ils sont pris par votre père
c'était comme ça j'étais l'étranger
voilà l'étranger alors un soir c'est
votre anniversaire vous tombez sous le
charme de Fernando Silva il était beau
j'avais 19 ans il m'a regardé
voilà on me remarque et voilà le 23
juillet 1968 vous accoucher de votre
fils Jeannot
là votre but c'est de vous installer en
France vous en pouvez plus du Portugal
vous pouvez plus de votre famille vous
êtes loin de votre mère et tout ça alors
vous débarquez donc à Paris en 1970 avec
dans une main Jeannot et dans l'autre de
la fameuse valise en carton quoi devenu
mondialement célèbre vous trouverez du
boulot comme femme de chambre dans un
hôtel la patronne vous loge et c'est là
que vous rencontrez doudou un monsieur
plus âgé que moi vous avez combien
d'années de plus que vous doudou oh
écoutez pour être très honnête avec vous
je pense qu'il pouvait être mon
grand-père
alors au départ ils vous engage pour
faire le ménage et puis après bon
t'attendrai c'est une idée donc voilà
mais j'avais honte de moi parce que vous
aviez le sentiment de vous prostituer
non non c'est pas de la prostitution
c'est de voir profiter financièrement de
quelqu'un parce que prostitution je me
suis jamais bien sûr c'est ce qu'on
appelle le Sugar Daddy quoi
c'est un vieux qui vous aime bien qui
vous entretient moi je voulais personne
m'a obligé de le dire avec moi c'est
vous qui le saviez alors là ça commence
à aller mieux vous bossez dans un hôtel
pas mal au Grand Hôtel rue Scribe juste
à côté de l'Opéra vous apprenez le
français en lisant nous deux et grâce à
nous deux vous installez dans un deux
pièces à Clichy et vous inscrivez
Jeannot à l'école maternelle donc là ça
commence à aller pas mal et un jour un
voisin vous fait découvrir un bistrot
qui s'appelle chez Louisette c'est un
restaurant au plus de Saint-Ouen et là
vous chantez pour la première fois en
public dans ces allers à Saint-Ouen
j'ai entendu des guitares
je rentre il y avait une jeune femme qui
chantait comme Piaf il y a un moment
donné je demande au patron est-ce que je
peux chanter moi aussi
et me voilà et à l'époque vous chantiez
beaucoup DJ l'amoros je vais vous
raconter
avant de commencer
l'histoire d'un petit village près de
Napoli nous étions quatre amis au bal
tout le samedi ah oui c'est une grande
fan de
[Applaudissements]
peu à peu votre notoriété augmente et en
1978 vous passez de l'aspirateur au
micro vous faites la connaissance de vin
buggy qui est une grande grande
parolière qui a beaucoup travaillé avec
Claude François traduit beaucoup de
chansons américaines elle écrivent vos
premiers textes vous sortez votre
premier 45 tours le Portugais gros
succès vous êtes produits par Claude
Carrère à l'époque et vous passez
évidemment comme tout le monde sauf moi
chez Michel Drucker
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et alors ensuite après ce premier 45
tours vous enchaînez avec un album vos
premiers concerts et vous vous installez
dans le 16e arrondissement quand même il
n'y avait des gens qui me prenaient pour
le concierge parce que j'étais
mais malheureusement Linda c'est là
aussi que s'organise la valse des
vautours vous n'avez même pas de compte
en banque et il faut dire vous soucier
pas des problèmes financiers vous sont
foutez c'est pas que je m'en foutais
Thierry je ne savais pas on s'occupait
de moi comme doudou c'est comme le père
de mon fils on me regarde en même et
voilà alors en 1981 vous rencontrez
Raymond robinet un éclairagiste qui
devient rapidement votre concubin il a
24 ans vous en avez 33 quand même
attendez fallait bien que je me rattrape
et c'est vrai c'est vrai que ce Raymond
robinet devient rapidement indispensable
alors pendant ce temps vous enchaînez
les tubes la fille qui pleurait tyroly
tirola Lisboa face à face l'étrangère
enfin bon les tubes énormes qui cette
époque cartonné à donf Aznavour écrit
pour vous Jean Ferrat écrit pour vous le
jour de votre premier Olympia c'est le
20 janvier 1983 vous savourez enfin
Linda votre revanche sur la vie toute la
famille est là ils sont tous venus sont
tous fiers de vous sauf votre mère
vous savez ce que j'ai compris
maintenant
des choses que j'ai découvertes je
comprends ouais puisque mon père m'a
fait avec une autre en 1984 ou publier
chez carrer Lafont la valise en carton
le conte de fées devient un phénomène de
librairie je crois que vous allez en
vendre 3 millions
le livre est adapté en comédie musicale
en série télé tout le monde vous dit
Linda Linda tu vas gagner des millions
et là en 1987 vous retrouvez sans argent
vous découvrez que la comédie musicale
et la série télé vous n'avez pas les
droits SACD c'est-à-dire que les gens
qu'on travaillait sur ces deux projets
nous vous ont pas déclaré en fait vous
savez
je ne connaissais pas tous ces liens ça
c'est des tous ces choses là voyez moi
je suis fâché avec les chiffres mais
c'est pas grave c'est pas parce que on
n'est pas comptable qu'on n'est pas
intelligent
en 1993 vous vous séparez de Raymond
j'ai le sentiment qui prenait un peu
d'argent vraiment quand même j'ai eu
cette petite intuition j'ai dit allez je
veux rester seul
à un moment cet argent il sait pas
évaporé
alors aujourd'hui donc après 20 millions
de dix et 3 millions de livres vous
vivez avec une petite retraite 400 euros
par mois vous dites j'ai même pas de
quoi acheter à manger à mon chien Tommy
toujours Tommy votre chien oui c'est mon
petit homme j'ai eu un petit cri de cœur
parce que vous savez parfois
je me sentais seul
mes petits-enfants je sais pas quoi ils
ressemblent
l'amour de ma vie mon enfant c'était les
plus belles douleurs de ma vie c'est
l'accouchement de mon enfant
Seigneur
vous faites des gala quand même oui
c'est une grande grande joie de refaire
la scène
la scène c'est ma maison et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu